[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue par le manque
d'eau 30 minutes pour faire le tour de
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
bonjour kaka bonjour michael et nous
accueillons une députée élue du 10 juin
2017 coralie dubost bonjour bonjour vous
avez été élue pour la troisième dans la
troisième circonscription de l'hérault
on a beaucoup de questions à vous poser
mais on va revoir d'abord les temps
forts de la semaine avec un remaniement
en forme de mini big bang plus de
ministres modem et 11 nouvelles têtes
sur la photo ils se sépareront
s'unissent pour former des groupes
parlementaires scission a droit de
recomposition agro à gauche et nouveau
groupe republic en marche et puis y
avait du monde à l'assemblée anciens et
nouveaux ont pris possession des lieux
on verra les images de cette rentrée
chorale et du besoin évidemment vous
interroger sur toutes ces questions
d'abord on va commencer par le
remaniement ministériel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cela devait être un ajustement technique
c'est devenu un big bang pour le nouveau
gouvernement fait lieu cette semaine
notamment avec le premier départ celui
de sylvie goulard aura tout ça c'est une
équipe élargie qui succède au premier
gouvernement d'edouard philippe
l'exécutif face de 22 à 29 membres
aucun centristes ne succèdent aux
ministres démissionnaires du modèle à la
justice françois bayrou est remplacée
par nicole belloubet membres du conseil
constitutionnel aux armes et florence
parly ancienne socialiste passé dans le
privé succède à sylvie goulard quant à
marielle de sarnez elle a été remplacée
aux affaires européennes par la
directrice de l'ena
nathalie l'oiseau mais le modem reste
représentée avec l'arrivée de la
sénatrice jacqueline gourault
vice-présidente du parti qui devient
ministre auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur
je suis très heureuse d'être ministre
auprès de gérard collomb que je connais
bien avec qui j'ai beaucoup travaillé
déjà au sénat nous sommes ensemble à la
commission des lois
nous étions ensemble à la commission des
lois et donc je vais le retrouver sur un
terrain que
j'ai beaucoup pratiqué c'est à dire les
collectivités locales
autre membre du modem geneviève
darrieussecq devient secrétaire d'état
auprès de la ministre des armées
au jeu des chaises musicales jacques
mézard quitte le ministère de
l'agriculture pour succéder à richard
ferrand à la cohésion des territoires
il est remplacé par le député en marche
stéphane travert autre arrivée
significative au gouvernement celle du
sénateur jean baptiste lemoyne
le premier parlementaire a l'air à avoir
rallié en marche devient secrétaire
d'état aux affaires étrangères
mais c'est vrai que c'est euh comment
dire qu'un peu d'émotion et une grande
fierté de savoir que présente la public
le maquereau le pré ministres font
confiance pour être utile derrière jean
yves le drian le ministre de l'europe et
des affaires étrangères et c'est le
sentiment aussi ben voilà de comment
dire tune charge d'une responsabilité
enfin benjamin griveaux fidèles
d'emmanuel macron devient secrétaire
d'état à l'économie et sébastien lecornu
proches de bruno le maire devient
secrétaire d'état à la transition
écologique chorale et du bot est ce que
ça vous gêne si on dit que ce
gouvernement est un gouvernement
d'experts de techniciens à ce n'est pas
seulement un gouvernement d'experts des
techniciens sait très bien qu'ils
expertisent dans un gouvernement bien
évidemment c'est surtout un gouvernement
de personnes qui sont engagées on n'a
pas évoqué non plus l'arrivée en
secrétariat d'état de julien de
normandie qui est avec eux de manuel
malgré le froid jeudi emmanuel macron
qui est à l'origine de l'aventuré en
marche qui a accompagné le mouvement
pendant toute la campagne présidentielle
et pendant la première partie il reste
politique mais vous le savez les
français ont choisi de changer les codes
de cette vie politique de donner leur
chance à des personnes qui sont issus de
la société civile
c'est la nouvelle façon de faire la
politique et c'est exactement ce qui a
été intégrée dans ce gouvernement
oui dont vous faites partie tout comme
brune poirson inconnu du grand public
qui est un peu le symbole comme vous de
la vague macron qui fait son entrée dans
ce gouvernement que ça nous faisons
partie de ces symboles là mais je pense
que nous sommes bien plus que deux si
vous regardez effectivement un à
l'échelle des élections législatives
beaucoup de députés aujourd'hui sont
issus de cette société civile
et apporte de nouvelles compétences dans
cette vie politique vous pensez que
c'est ce que veulent les français que ce
set cette nouvelle composition va va
plaire à l'opinion publique je pense que
les français veulent donner leur chance
à cette façon de composer la vie
politique après que ce soit pour le
gouvernement pour les députés
bien évidemment que la responsabilité
est immense est ce que ça vous gêne
également je reprends un petit peu ma
question mais ce que ça vous gêne qui
ont dit qu on a affaire avec emmanuel
macron un hyperprésident un hyper
président oui où les décisions se
prennent quasiment tout et tout
à l'elysée on parle de toujours même de
politique je pense qu'on a à faire un
président pas exactement
nous avons à faire un président qui a
pris son mandat dès l'origine avec
beaucoup de stature avec une beaucoup de
posture et qui tient à ce que la france
le gouvernement soit pilotée par notre
ministre notre premier ministre edouard
philippe
ce qui est le cas c'étaient des filles
qui a présenté à emmanuel macron sa
feuille de route pour le gouvernement
deux postes législatives et ensuite que
la discussion existe ça me semble
parfaitement normal donc c'est un retour
à un équilibre qui était censé être
celui initialement prévu par les
institutions de la vème république le
président préside le gouvernement
gouverne c'est un peu ça c'est bien ça
nous sommes dans l'esprit de la vème
république avec une constitution qui est
parfaitement clair qui avait été un
petit peu dévoyé dans la pratique qu'ils
la retrouvent toutes ses lettres de
noblesse ya une personnalité politique
n'est plus dans ce gouvernement qu'il
l'était c'est françois bayrou
cette semaine il a donc quitté son poste
dit il
re d'accord avec emmanuel macron bien
évidemment est ce que pour vous c'est
une perte
écoutez c'est un choix c'est un chat
qu'il faut respecter
il a indiqué par ailleurs qu'il
resterait l'un des piliers de cette
majorité je pense qu'effectivement c'est
une chose importante que le modem reste
un pilier de la majorité s'étaient
également indiqué qu'il resterait lui
l'un des modèles qu'il participerait
avec le modem à l'exécution de ce plan
de transformation nous avions porté dans
le cas de la présidentielle et nous
avait rallié parce qu'ils adhéraient à
certaines valeurs a une vision un projet
l'urgence est aujourd'hui véritablement
de d'engager ses réformes de les mettre
en oeuvre
donc tout l'enjeu est là et il fait
partie de cette majorité il sera il sera
donc aux côtés d' emmanuel macron et ce
ne sera pas l'un des opposants emmanuel
macron comme on a pu le lire absolument
pas positionnés
de façon à être en notre position mais
bien au contraire a participé à cette
construction de façon probablement très
exigeante et c'est nécessaire dans une
démocratie de qualité mais dans le cas
de la majorité pour vous c'est la
démission de françois bayrou c'est la
conclusion logique d'une longue séquence
des politiques potosi c'est un choix
c'est un choix qu'il faut respecter moi
je salue aussi le choix de sylvie
goulard que j'ai trouvée est tout à fait
honorable et je pense que ça ça donne
une conséquence qui est logiquement la
suite alors cette semaine évidemment à
l'assemblée nationale il ya eu beaucoup
de tractations pour former les groupes
politiques tractations et discussions
lui d'abord et surtout à droite ou de
groupe o finalement été créé avec la
scission notamment d'une partie des
républicains qui sont aller siéger avec
des membres de l'udf et cécile martel
qui nous explique tout cela après des
jours de tractations la rupture est
officialisée
thierry solère député des hauts-de-seine
annonce la création d'un nouveau groupe
à l'assemblée
les républicains constructif udi
indépendant des députés qui en majorité
contre voté la confiance au gouvernement
d'edouard philippe essais en n'étant pas
dans des postures et en aidant des
réformes qui vont dans le bon sens qu'on
participe à ce que le pays
enfin connaissent les réformes qu'il
attend pour l'instant une vingtaine
d'élus et l'air et 18 députés udi compte
y participer
la liste exacte et le président de ce
groupe seront connus mardi prochain en
réponse les républicains canal
historique tente de minimiser la
fracture c'est un choix individuel c'est
moi je pense que chacun en revanche la
maison est ouverte nous avons toujours
été dans cet état d'esprit on a connu
des tensions dans notre famille
politique on a même connu deux groupes
parlementaires à une époque et ce sont
ces retrouver ça n'a pas ça n'a pas duré
dans le temps au bureau politique devant
nos micros personne n'appelle à
l'exclusion des dissidents jean pierre
raffarin défend l'idée que les deux
lignes peuvent coexister où nous allons
imaginons une structure confédérale
imaginons une approche qui fait vivre
les gens ensemble et à ce moment là
l'avenir sera un avenir groupés ou alors
c'est la raideur qu'ils l'emportent et à
ce moment là deux familles politiques
pourront exister
bernard accoyer secrétaire général du
parti a saisi les instances de
l'assemblée nationale pour que les
constructif n'utilise pas le nom des
républicains
emmanuel macron hacker fait exploser la
grotte ce sont les français qui ont fait
exploser le paysage politique je pense
le gouvernement est parfaitement
équilibré les députés de la majorité de
la république en marche ont été élus
avec ce gouvernement puis le gouvernent
confirmée par le gouvernement remanié le
fait que les républicains réfléchi se
remettent en cause des sites de
nouvelles structures me semble là aussi
tout à leur honneur dans la mesure où
ils prennent en considération les
différents messages envoyés par leur
sens et c'est une partie des
républicains qui s'intitule donc les
voies la réponse de lily ça veut dire
que ce sera quand même un groupe
d'appoint pour vous groupe majoritaire
dans cette nouvelle assemblée ce serait
un petit peu des alliés pensent que ce
qui est important c'est qu'on puisse
effectivement passer ses réformes
rapidement dans un contexte et dans un
climat à l'assemblée qu'ils soient de
qualité parce que nous l'avions vu sur
les législatives le taux d'abstention
des français de plus en plus fort la
lecture vis-à-vis du monde politique est
de plus en plus sévères ça nous
appellent à énormément de
responsabilités au-delà des clivages au
delà des nouveaux guides et nouveau
mouvement a travaillé en bonne
intelligence il faut du soutien du
soutien de la bonne intelligence dit
presque sept groupes l'assemblée
nationale sinon il ya presque sept
groupes oui assemblée nationale c est
une première depuis 1958 est ce un
challenge s'annonce anthony c'est trop
tard pour vous ce que ça représentait
est ce que c'est une explosion de tous
les partis ou est-ce qu'au contraire
c'est la nouvelle façon de faire de la
politique c'est une étape nous verrons
de quelle façon cela évolue c'est une
étape mais vous savez depuis plus d'une
année des étapes nous avons passé de
relativement spectaculaire et tout s'est
très bien passé donc je n'ai aucun doute
que nous allons pouvoir avancer de sète
va demander aujourd'hui à ces nouveaux
constructive de vraiment de vous
accompagner de vaud que la confiance
d'aller voter les textes c'est un appel
que développer la confiance bien
évidemment de regarder les textes
pour l'exécuter intelligemment bien
évidemment aussi alors tous ne voteront
pas forcément la confiance notamment les
canal historique dlr pour eux pour vous
ça se fait ce parti fait partie du passé
nous verrons comment ils se positionnent
c'est simplement la rentrée nous sommes
dans les premiers temps nous allons voir
de quelle façon cela évolue mais
effectivement si il y à des postures
relativement rigide qui se construisent
qui se déconstruisent en se positionnant
un an de l'opposition cela appartient
beaucoup plus au passé alors olivier
faure a été lui réélu ce jeudi patron du
groupe socialiste à l'assemblée il aura
la lourde tâche de fédérer la trentaine
de députés socialistes rescapés de la
déroute électorale des législatives si
on peut dire ça comme ça corallites
dubost ce sera pas facile pour olivier
faur vous pensez que les socialistes en
leur majorité vont voter aussi la
confiance au gouvernement philippe jeu 4
juillet les socialistes sont encore en
discussion ils sont en train de se
repositionner
c'est tout de même un séisme qui l'a et
qui les a saisies est donc ça leur prend
un peu de temps et cela se comprend
parfaitement
nous verrons comment cela évolue mais
effectivement je souhaitais olivier faur
beaucoup d'énergie et de courage par
avance et vous avant de rejoindre la
république en moi je vous étiez de
quelle sensibilité plutôt à gauche je
n'étais ni d'une sensibilité mais de
l'autre je n'avais pas d'engagement
politique et c'est votre coeur est
balancé + gauche à droite et dans ma vie
j'ai déjà voté à gauche et déjà votre
droite est déjà au centre
je ne m'étais jamais encarté est
précisément chez en marche cette
dimension qui était hors clivage en
revanche autour de valeurs et d'un
projet concret commun cela ça me
convenait on va passer à l'autre partie
de la gauche peut-être une autre gauche
où vous allez pouvoir commenter bien
évidemment celle de la france insoumise
notamment ils sont arrivés groupés à
l'assemblée nationale vous avez
certainement vu cette image de jean luc
mélenchon arrivant ici avec les
parlementaires les communistes eux ont
décidé de faire bande à part les deux
formations mais n'ont pas réussit tout
simplement à se mettre d'accord
c'est un récit des tractations que vous
propose françois moulin
dans ce bras de fer entre frères ennemis
c'est jean luc mélenchon qui entame les
hostilités dès dimanche dernier au soir
du second tour des législatives il
annonce la couleur
le peuple français dispose à l'assemblée
nationale d'un goût la france insoumise
avec tous ceux qui voudront le rejoindre
et qui sont les bienvenus un groupe donc
à l'assemblée nationale mais aucune
mention des élus communistes et
d'impossible groupe commun en coulisses
le siège de jean luc mélenchon au
parlement européen est au coeur des
tractations
il le répète dès son arrivée mardi au
palais bourbon sa suppléante communiste
doit se retirer au profit de son ancien
directeur de campagne
sinon il n'y aura pas d'accord si mon
arrivée ici donne lui au fait que mon
poste de député européen qui normalement
de les passer au suivant qui est manuel
bompard si ça ça n'est pas réglé donc si
l'accord précédent n'est pas respectée
on ne peut pas envisager qu'il y en ait
de nouveau mais surtout on va je pense
qu'ils vont être raisonnable les députés
communistes ne l'entendent pas de cette
oreille
marie pierre vieu la suppléante de jean
luc mélenchon sera député européenne et
après des heures de discussions et de
coups de fil la décision tombe il y aura
un groupe autonome de onze élus
communistes et de quatre élus
d'outre-mer
pour nous ce qui est le plus important
c'est le travail en commun que l'on peut
conduire avec le groupe des insoumis
c'est réfléchir à la façon de faire à
l'espace que l'on peut créer certains
nouveaux députés investi lors de la
campagne des législatives par les deux
formations regrette que les dissensions
prennent le pas sur un accord politique
mais en toile de fond se dessine une
problématique bien plus vénales le
financement des deux parties chaque
député leur rapporte plus de 37000 euros
pas question pour la france insoumise et
pour les communistes de laisser cet
argent à leurs alliés
avec jean luc mélenchon vous estimez
avoir une force d'opposition dure à
l'assemblée nationale écoutez la
position de jean luc mélenchon est
effectivement très dur nous l'avions vu
dans le cadre des deux campagnes c'est
de la stricte opposition par principe
sans véritable débat
donc nous verrons comment nous ne savons
pas vous fait peur justement ces débats
qui pourraient avoir lieu dans la soirée
à l'assemblée dans l'hémicycle ah non
les débats ne mettrait pas du tout je
serais ravi qu'il ait des débats et
surtout de l'échangé de l' échange de
qualité donc j'ai entendu le parti
communiste qui nous parlait de travail
de réflexion je préfère quand on emploie
ces mots là plutôt que lorsque l'on se
pose dans une posture strictes puisque
même sur le droit du travail par exemple
ils ont déjà dit et jean luc mélenchon
au premier qu'il serait le premier des
opposants et vous avez entendu peut-être
cette phrase battant qui a été célèbre
sur les réseaux sociaux notamment de
jean luc mélenchon à propos de cédric
villani qu'est votre confrère notamment
un nouveau député
le matheux comme il l'appelle qui n'a
jamais connu que le contrat de travail
qu'est ce que ça que ça dit du débat
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'il y a
beaucoup de stéréotypes et caricatures
voire de préjugés de biais cognitifs a
travaillé chez jean luc mélenchon pour
réduire et cédric villani aux matheux
qui par ailleurs connaît
particulièrement bien les contres
travail pour avoir dirigé un institut et
pour en avoir
je verrai quelques-uns mais pour vous
c'est une forme de mépris de dire ça le
matin comme ça ça vous instant vous
savez je pense que c'est plutôt une
forme d'angoise jean luc mélenchon se
retrouve face à des profils qu'il ne
connaît pas des gens qu'il n'a pas su
faire monter manifestement au sein de
son parti à des gens qui les français
font confiance des gens de qualité d'
expertise de talent il ne sait pas
comment ils les aborder il est réduit à
ce qui les ferait donc voix se faisaient
à quoi face à la nouvelle façon de faire
de la politique par rapport à une sorte
de 10 par rapport à ces profils qui
arrive avec une expertise données et
cédric villani n'incarne tout
particulièrement puisque son expertise
est reconnue à l'échelle mondiale et qui
seront selon vous faire entendre leur
voix aux efforts dans l'hémicycle en
tout cas faire entendre leur voix même
si il y aura d'un côté jean luc
mélenchon de l'autre
eh ben il le fait ce sera pas facile
d'exister de se faire entendre vous
savez je pense qu'il ya plusieurs façons
de se faire entendre
soit l'on peut sortir des grandes
phrases des phrases chocs des grandes
lignes et puis il ya aussi la qualité du
travail le sérieux la rigueur la
compétence qui est apportée compter sur
ça et nous comptons énormément sur ce
seul argument la compétence la
méthodologie et les solides avants pour
autant cela m'est sorti des conseils des
ministres a entendu par un mot sinon ce
travail c'est une consigne c'est une
consigne c'est une responsabilité c'est
une humilité
nous ne sommes pas ici seulement pour
faire de grandes phrases nous sembla
pour faire avancer les choses nous le
savons nous avons seulement cinq années
c'est très bref sans canne et
transformer tout le pays toutes les
réformes qui sont nécessaires nous
devons rester concentrés alors eux aussi
ont fait la rentrée sous les caméras et
sous la canicule les élus du front
national et apparentés ils entendent
donc compté dans la nouvelle assemblée
est ce que vous pensez que le front
national va réussir à former ce qui
l'attend un groupe parlementaire
c'est-à-dire 15 députés
pour l'instant il y en a huit si on en
rajoute quelques heures et si
quelques-uns dlr viennent vers marine le
pen peut y avoir ce groupe si vous
pensez qu'ils réussiront à écouter pour
l'instant inexistant il n'y sont pas et
nous verrons je ne le souhaite pas parce
que ça vous a fait peur cette image de
marine le pen arrivant donc déjà élu à
l'assemblée mais presque aux portes de
pouvoir ça vous fait peur marine le pen
ne me fait pas peur le front national ne
me fait pas peur de façon globale en
revanche où il lui il joue beaucoup sur
les peurs et cherche à susciter ce type
de sentiments non et puis écouter dans
l'est
législatives au second tour on a vu même
en premier on avait une grande
démobilisation de l'électorat du front
national
de ce point de vue là il me semble avoir
s'être largement affaibli et je pense
que ce sera compliqué pour eux de vendre
malgré les huit députés
coralie dubost il ya eu une proposition
qui a été mis sur la table hier parce
qu'il ya eu des députés qui ont refusé
un député qui reflète heureux de voir la
justice marine le pen elle ira sur
l'immunité parlementaire notamment cette
suppression de l'immunité parlementaire
a dit y êtes-vous favorable à l'or
l'immunité parlementaire il faut pouvoir
la conserver pour qu'un député puisse
assurer sa fonction pour qu'il puisse
avoir aussi une liberté d'expression
dans le cadre du débat sinon ce serait
très compliqué pour lui de mener à bien
sa tâche sa mission en revanche il y à
certains cas pour lesquels leur devoir
moral exige effectivement de se rendre
donc nous y est favorable au passage à
l'as eu pour être fier non non non je ne
suis pas loin à la suppression des mines
de l'immunité parlementaire
d'accord il ya eu le porte parole du
gouvernement quand même qui a dit que je
ne serai pas opposé à cela donc c'est
peut-être un premier relais mais sa
suppression pure et dure je pense qu'on
peut pas du jour au lendemain passer de
tout au tout il faut la réfléchir c'est
simplement vous pose la question de la
suppression le radical non simplement ça
doit se réfléchir si ça doit être
remodelé alors cette semaine il y avait
du monde à nouveau à l'assemblée
beaucoup d'animations dans les couloirs
nous allons faire un petit retour sur le
parcours des nouveaux députés notamment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fraîchement élu ou député plus
chevronnés ils ont fait leur retour au
palais bourbon le récit de maïté frémont
ce couloir qui mène dans l'hémicycle
deviendra dans quelques semaines une
routine pour ces nouveaux députés
mais en attendant ils font ici leurs
premiers pas guidé ils découvrent leur
nouveau lieu de travail
après quelques clichés souvenirs de ce
moment historique c'est à eux de prendre
la pose pour la photo officielle
votre rôle montoro la manette en main
ces députés débutants sont attendus par
les journalistes dans la salle des
quatre colonnes tout ça il est dans
cette enveloppe il ya une petite boîte
avec des fers tricolore avec un petit
pin cela quand on a l'honneur d'être un
parlementaire on se sent un peu aussi
comment dirais-je chargé d'histoire on
pense à repenser aux anciens très
émouvant mais pour le reste
pour le reste je vais un peu mieux ses
portes et maintenant pour cette journée
je parle
l'heure est pour le moment à la
découverte mais très vite ces députés
devront rentrer dans le combat politique
par rapport à tout ce qu'on a entendu
pendant la campagne on nous a dit en
gros vous n'aurez pas le droit à
l'erreur il faut que vous soyez au
travail je voulais montrer que manière
symbolique même si la session commence
la semaine prochaine
on était au travail dès le premier jour
j'ai une responsabilité cette
responsabilité c'est aussi de ma
d'appliquer le programme d' emmanuel
macron donc je me suis engagé sur
l'édition tier c'est ma responsabilité
et puis après je serai quelqu'un et lui
constructif donc j'apporterai aussi ma
pierre personnel cet édifice qu'est le
programmes des manuels sur les 577 424
élus n'ont jamais été députée
ils auront toute la semaine pour prendre
leurs marques avant de siéger sur ses
bancs de l'assemblée le 27 juin prochain
alors chorale et du boss vous avez vous
aussi fait ce parcours en tant que
nouvel élu qu'est ce que vous avez
ressenti au moment de prendre votre mal
est du député de pas mal est là on
attend de vue on avait prévenu des
rendez vous suivant à assurer de façon
administrative donc je pensais déjà au
suivant a long parcours
un long parcours qui est bien normal
hein vous prenez une nouvelle fonction
l'émotion si de l'émotion oui l'émotion
ça a été plus le dimanche soir l'émotion
sera je pense à la rentrée plus
solennelle et nous sommes encore dans le
cadre de l'installation et de la
découverte
alors justement sur toute cette
installation sur tout autre parcours
pour cinq ans qui vont arriver
le rapport en parler avec notre
partenaire du figaro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jaras et bonjour vocal bonjour katia
bonjour coralie dubost ce week-end vous
réunissez avec claude vos collègues
marcheurs à l'hôtel de la ces pour un
séminaire de rentrée
à quoi ça va servir à vous apprendre des
députés le discipliner
non c'est un peu caricatural c'est un
séminaire de travail déjà nous allons
nous retrouver pour ceux qui se
connaissent déjà nous rencontrer pour
ceux du groupe qui émerge de la
république en marche qui sont des
profils de sociétés civiles émergents on
avait moins rencontrer
nous avons des sujets précis a commencé
à travailler ensemble comme nous le
faisions auparavant dans le cadre des
différentes étapes du mouvement cheikh
en marche
les référents par exemple se retrouver
très régulièrement leur travail certains
sujets il ya quand même une lettre à
suivre assez stricte chez vous puisque
lors de votre investiture vous avez
signé un contrat d'engagement qui vous
engage justement à voter pour les six
principaux chantiers de la majorité
parmi lesquelles la réforme valois
travail ou la lutte contre le terrorisme
est ce que vous n'avez pas l'impression
que sur ces deux sujets importants comme
cela les députés devraient pouvoir
apporter de la nuance devait pouvoir
finalement donné leur avis la nuance est
un excellent terme est précisément le
contrat que vous avez évoquées qui a été
signé au départ à l'origine il faut y
mettre de la nuance n'est absolument pas
un contrat rigide c'est un contrat sur
lequel on s'engage sur des valeurs qu'il
ya des valeurs il ya un projet il ya des
grands ensembles et mangue votre contre
phil donc je connais ton nom s'engage à
vous le pont le contrat dont vous avez
parlé celui que nous avons signé nous
sommes engagés sur des valeurs respecter
des valeurs et à respecter comme j'ai
des photos y sont des grandes lignes
sont des grandes lignes de loi que vous
dans le contrat que vous ne pouvez pas
faire ce dévoiement là les textes qui
arriveront ne sont pas ceux de ce
contrat donc par exemple sur la loi
moralisation ou le texte sur le
terrorisme que vous pourriez voté contre
ça ne fait pas partie du contrat non mon
idée aujourd'hui de voter contre
j'attends d'eux non mais attendez
il faut faire les choses par étapes
attendant que les textes viennent nous
allons les lire nous allons en discuter
nous allons les regarder mais a priori
lorsque cela correspond un projet
présidentiel que vous avez porté pendant
plus d'une année
soutenue et que vous avez soutenu
pendant la campagne législative serait
cohérent que vous vous sortez le droit
de pouvoir dire non c'est ça la vraie
question
je me sens le droit de pouvoir dialoguer
alors en attendant les textes ce qui n'a
pas encore d'or du jour de l'assemblée
juste savoir votre position parce que
vous dites vous êtes engagés sur des
valeurs le comité national d'éthique va
rendre un avis important sur la
nécessité ou pas d'ouvrir les techniques
d'assistance médicale à la procréation
qui sont actuellement réservées aux
couples infertiles
est ce que vous êtes plutôt pour ou
contre cette ouverture notamment aux
couples de femmes
alors le couple des femmes nous nous y
étions déjà engagés pendant la campagne
nous y sommes favorables
vous oui sans hésitation et vous pensez
que c'est la position partagée par tous
ça faisait partie du programme
présidentiel elle emmanuel macron
nourrir la bm à tout pour tout le cadre
rigide il va aussi concerner l'élection
de votre président le groupe puisqu'il
n'y aura qu'un seul candidat il s'agit
de richard ferrand certains dans votre
groupe 10 bat finalement on aurait bien
aimé avoir le choix entre plusieurs
candidats puisque l'on sait qu'il ya
quand même un contexte particulier
concernant richard ferrand qu'est ce que
vous en pensez vous je pense que richard
ferrand l'a depuis l'origine qu'il a été
un excellent secrétaire général du
mouvement qui nous a soutenu qu'il a été
celui qui a apporté de la cohérence
pendant la totalité de la campagne qui a
accompagné les référents il a fait
émerger les profils de sociétés civiles
aussi dans les candidatures
c'est très important et là la joue un
rôle très important aussi sur les
députés qui sont aujourd'hui élu de la
république en marche il a participé à
ces choix là il a consolidé le mouvement
et parce que non je suis tout à fait
favorable à sa présidence au groupe
d'accord pendant ce séminaire est ce que
vous allez avoir des déformations de
média training
alors vous vous débrouillez très bien
sur ce plateau tv pendant la campagne
des législatives
on se souvient il ya eu quelques
dérapages qui ont été un peu rails et
sur les réseaux sociaux
est ce que ça va faire partie justement
de deux thèmes que vous allez aborder ce
week-end n'a pas écouté je n'ai pas le
programme du week end sous des yeux
peut-être que ça peut être une idée si
certains le demandent et pense en avoir
besoin
l'idée de toute façon c'est d'être dans
l'accompagnement et la solidarité ça
peut se faire aussi de façon informelle
en bilatéral accompagné quelques-uns
mais les premières fois dans les médias
ça peut toujours être intimidant le
compte
bien on a parlé de la présidence du
groupe de la république en marche il va
aussi avoir l'élection du président de
l'assemblée
est-ce que vous avez un profil en tête
et ce que vous souhaiteriez par exemple
ce soit une femme
alors je n'ai pas un profil défini en
tête mais je ne suis pas contre j'ai un
peu les lignes de sur ce postulat que ce
serait une bonne chose que vous avez le
nom exemple je serais ravi que ce soit
une femme
mais je n'ai pas de nom vous n'avez pas
de niablé maintenant on vous en parlait
pas entre vous ça c'est des débats qui
doivent émerger en ce moment oui qui
émarge vous savez on a beaucoup de
travail
déjà à mettre en oeuvre à titre
personnel il ya beaucoup de choses qui
échangent en très peu de temps
non simplement ce sur quoi nous
discutons c'est sur cette idée de
changer la projection des
responsabilités et la façon dont elles
sont assumés voilà quand les du buzz
vous savez vous à titre personnel ce que
vous voulez faire à l'assemblée
nationale dans quelles conditions ou
est-ce que vous laissiez j'ai ce que
voulait faire alors j'ai demandé
certaines commissions oui j'ai une idée
ce qui me plaît ce que j'aimerais faire
on verra après la façon c'est possible
se répartir dans l'idéal j'aimerais
beaucoup être à la commission des lois
donc beaucoup donc projet de loi l'état
d'urgence ou de travail qui attend la
caution il doit tout à fait beaucoup
d'amis 3 en plus à l'assemblée
oui qui a une transversalité bon aurez
l'occasion de vous suivre à ce moment là
merci mobile va accepter l'invitation de
parlement hebdo hafid gym et on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine sur lcp
public sénat
[Musique]